[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
the house system and a popular what if
scenario
that has been leaving fans curious for
years
what if harry potter the boy who lived
was sorted into slytherin
what makes this question so compelling
is that harry is such a quintessential
gryffindor
showing his immense bravery on numerous
occasions throughout the series
furthermore harry being in sutherin
would presumably
alter the course of the entire series
let's dive
right into it now when the books first
start out
harry is just an innocent downtrodden
young man he's trapped in the boring
muggle world
with no real concept of the wizarding
world and he has some of the worst
adoptive parents
that you could ask for right from the
very beginning you feel for harry
and you can't help but think of all of
the hardship that he has had to endure
up to that point when harry starts
nearing the appropriate age to start
attending hogwarts
one of the most famous magical schools
in the wizarding world
he starts getting hogwarts letters in
the mail this happens because of the
book of admittance
and quill of acceptance little did he
know that when his name was first
inscribed in the book of admittance
it would change his life forever when
the hogwarts letters started piling in
harry's uncle vernon knew exactly what
was up
and vehemently disallowed harry from
opening any of the letters scent
despite them being addressed to him
fortunately
however dumbledore and hagrid are more
than privy to harry's
unique circumstances and hagrid ends up
hand delivering the acceptance letter to
harry
ensuring that he is aware of the
upcoming school year
after a brief explanation from hagrid
introing the wizarding world
harry travels to diagon alley where he
picks up all of his school supplies
at first it's overwhelming but at the
same time it's exciting
as it indicates a new chapter in harry's
life a chapter
full of excitement and magic what we
need to remember though
is that harry despite his reputation
wasn't yet a strong person
he had a rough start to his life the
only influences he had were his adoptive
family
who were awful and he must have been
highly impressionable
not before long harry finds himself on
the hogwarts express
sharing a compartment with a somewhat
shy yet friendly
ron weasley together the pair make a
journey from platform nine and
three-quarters at king's cross station
in london
to hogwarts for the very first time
however
harry's previously tranquil and
confusing first journey to hogwarts
is not without altercation shortly after
harry and ron have introduced themselves
draco crabb and goyle all burst into
their compartment
curious to see if it's true that the
harry potter
is coming to hogwarts after insulting
ron due to his appearance
red hair freckles shabby looking must be
a weasley
draco offers what i believe is meant to
be his best piece of advice
along with his outstretched hand you'll
soon find out some wizarding families
are much better than others
potter you don't want to go making
friends with the wrong sort
i can help you there he held at his hand
to shake harry's
of course in the book harry quickly
rejects this offering
with the sentence ending with but harry
didn't take it
but what if he had what if in that
moment
he had hesitated ever so slightly paused
just long enough to think well what's
the harm in keeping my options open
who really knows who these two boys are
who's to say that ron weasley
would make a better ally than reggae
malfoy in this new
and intimidating world i found myself
thrown into
like i stated earlier harry is young and
massively
impressionable he was thrust into a
magical world
with no prior knowledge of it and now
he's being put in pressure situations
where he's having to assess
on the spot which company is right for
him
but i'll also say this harry's
willingness to accept or deny draco's
handshake
does not necessarily have any bearing on
what house he would end up in
it just means that things might be a bit
more awkward for him once he sorted into
slytherin
having instead chosen the friendship of
someone in a rival house
however for the sake of the video i'm
going to proceed on the basis that harry
did accept draco's handshake
a decision that would already send him
in a very different direction
than the harry we're used to and so
instead of immediately rebuffing draco
and making an enemy
he reaches out and meets draco's hand
perhaps he does so while looking at the
floor
and even blushes a little feeling a bit
ashamed for not standing up for ron
who had just been so nice to him once
they reach hogwarts and the sorting
ceremony begins
harry listens to the sorting hat's song
along with the rest of the students
paying special attention to the
following verses there's nothing hidden
in your head
the sorting hat can't see so try me on
and i will tell you
where you ought to be students begin to
get sorted into their houses
and harry sees malfoy his new and
potentially only
ally become a member of slytherin house
so
what could be so bad about joining a
house with someone who's offered to show
him the ropes of the wizarding world
and then as if answering this thought
when harry is called up for his
placement
the sorting hat shares you could be
great you know
it's all here in your head and slytherin
will help you on the way to greatness
no doubt about that and instead of
fighting it
harry embraces it thinking that doesn't
sound so bad
after all slytherin isn't inherently bad
in spite of the brush that it's painted
with
from harry's perspective he might
question why it would even be an option
as a house
if it was as bad as some people said
house biases are a
very real thing and it just so happened
that harry's initial friendships in the
existing story
were students that came from gryffindor
of course they were going to be pro
gryffindor and
auntie slytherin their rivals with that
being said
upon the sorting hat's declaration that
harry was indeed a slytherin
nothing would have been the same for him
obviously the first major difference
would have been his friendships at
hogwarts
hard to have best friends in
sutherland's rival house of gryffindor
especially if you've slighted one of
those people before you even really got
to know them
and it's highly unlikely that harry's
new pal draco
would have accepted hermione granger a
mudblood
or witchborn of muggle parents as
acceptable company
and so harry would have continued to
develop a friendship with draco
this bond likely would have pushed crab
and goyle out of draco's immediate crew
who needs bodyguards friends when you
have the great and famous
harry potter as your bestie due to
harry's interest in quidditch
or at least his interest in being in the
team harry may have still ended up
playing the sport
but for slytherin house perhaps he would
have intentionally ousted southern's
former seeker
terence higgs in his first year at
hogwarts
fueled by his developing maliciousness
or maybe
he would have waited until lucius malfoy
draco's dear dad
donated enough nimbus 2001 broomsticks
to the entire southern quidditch team in
their second year
resulting in both harry and draco being
welcomed onto the team
harry and draco may have fought over who
played seeker but something tells me
harry would have earned the role being
the talented and famous
harry potter in either case i think
harry would have still been enthusiastic
about the game of quidditch just on a
different team
and so similarly to his friendships
harry's other relationships also would
have been affected
most notably his mentors instead of
albus dumbledore
hogwarts headmaster the obvious choice
would have been the head of southern
house
severus snape with harry's placement in
southern
rather than gryffindor perhaps snape
would have sooner revealed his past
connection with harry's mother lily
and seen less of a resemblance between
harry and his dad
james who was of course a gryffindor
with
snape as harry's mentor there would have
been little reason for dumbledore to get
so involved in harry's life
and progression through hogwarts as he
already would have had the guidance of
severus
and with draco openly referring to likes
of hagrid as
riff raff it would have been unlikely
that harry pursued any further
interactions
the lowly school game keeper harry's
love interests and romantic
inclinations would have also been
impacted hard to see him firing up a
romance with ginny weasley
after so many years of bad blood between
harry and ron
which would have been a direct result of
the handshake with draco
i guess it's possible that he may have
still had a relationship with
ravenclaw's
cho chang but something tells me this
version of harry
would have been more interested in
someone a little less kind
and a little more ruthless like say
pansy parkinson
leader of a gang of girls from southern
house who were often associated with
draco and his crew
it stands to reason that pansy who was
seen to be romantically linked to
or at least interested in draco
throughout the series
may have even become involved in a love
triangle between malfoy and harry
if harry had been a suitor perhaps he
would have been the one to take pansy to
the yule ball
in the goblet of fire not draco from
there
who knows what might have happened i
think that if harry was sorted into
slytherin
there's a large chance that he could
have adopted the role that draco plays
in each of the books replacing malfoy as
the villain
as an orphan who lost his parents at
such a young age
and who was badly mistreated by his
extended family for his entire childhood
it really doesn't seem that far-fetched
that harry could have become this series
antagonist
rather than its protagonist can't you
just see it
a malicious version of harry replacing
draco in each of malfoy's scenes
perhaps he would have even been the one
sought out by voldemort
to assassinate dumbledore which begs the
question
if harry had become the villain who
would have carried out the adventures of
harry potter
who would have stopped professor
quirrell voldemort from getting the
philosopher's stone
who would have overshadowed cedric
diggory in the triwizard tournament
and who would have hunted down
voldemort's horcruxes alongside ron
and hermione flipping the switch
entirely i think that another
what if outcome from harry being sorted
into slytherin
is that he influenced slytherin house
for the better giving a positive
impression
onto draco coyle crabb and all of the
other slytherins who embraced him
we see harry grow up with an intense
rivalry with draco
but who's to say that if he had grown up
alongside him
some of harry's innate positive traits
couldn't have rubbed off on him
maybe harry's nature and sorting into
slytherin could have resulted in a more
unified hogwarts
if you want i'll elaborate on that
what-if scenario
in another video anyway i hope you
enjoyed today's video
if you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time remember
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you